كشف تحقيق لرويتيرز ان رحلات الاغاثه
الانسانيه العاجله المتوجهه من ايران الى
سوريا بعد زلزال السادس من فبراير لم تكن
محمله بالمساعدات بل بمعدات عسكريه تسعه
مصادر سوريه وايرانيه واسرائيليه وغربيه
قالت لرويترز ان ايران استخدمت رحلات
لاغاثه الجويه لادخال اسلحه ومعدات عسكريه
الى حليفتها سوريا وتحديدا عبر مطارات حلب
ودمشق واللاذقيه بحسب المصادرز الهدف كان
دعم دفاعات ايران ضد اسرائيل في سوريا
وتعزيز الدفاعات السوريه التابعه لنظام
الاسد تضمنت الامدادات ومعدات اتصالات
المتطوره وبطاريات الرادار وقطع غيار
مطلوبه لنظام الدفاع الجوي السوري الذي
قدمته ايران بحسب مصادر اقليميه
واستخباراتيه غربيه لرويتورز المبعوث
الايراني الى الامم الم بدوره استخدام
بلاده لطائرات اغاثه انسانيه بعد وقوع
الزلازل لنقل معدات عسكريه الى سوريا في
المقابل رصدت اسرائيل تحركات كبيره لنقل
معدات عسكريه ايرانيه تحت ستار شحنات
مساعدات الزلزال الى سوريا وتم نقلها على
شكل قطع متفرقه مسؤول تابع للدفاع
الاسرائيلي قال ان المساعدات سلمت بشكل
اساسي الى مطار حلب شمالي سوريا وان
الشحنات كانت تنظم من قبل وحده تابعه
لفيلق القدس التابع للحرس الثوري
كان رده فعل وجهت اسرائيل ضربه لمدرج حلب
بعد ساعتين فقط من هبوط طائرات الشحن
الايرانيه المحمله بالاسلحه المتنكره على
شكل مواد اغافيه بحسب مصدر اقليمي ومصدرين
استخباراتيين غربيين لرويترز رش خياط
العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات